merci tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
écoutez on a eu un message clair les
Québécois
ont envoyé un message fort ce soir les
Québécois nous ont dit
[Applaudissements]
continuer
et
vous savez
[Applaudissements]
c'est une victoire qui est historique
parce que ce soir
je suis tellement fier de ça on a fait
élire le plus grand nombre de femmes de
toute l'histoire
[Applaudissements]
quelle belle gang
ça veut dire que le travail commence par
exemple pour le deuxième mandat puis
je vais le répéter là je le disais parce
que il y en a quelques-uns quelques-unes
ici pour qui là c'est tellement vrai la
priorité des priorités ça doit rester
l'éducation ça doit rester l'éducation
[Applaudissements]
et moi là
Sainte-Anne-de-Bellevue qui est devenu
premier ministre tout ce que j'ai dans
vie c'est à cause de mes parents c'est à
cause de l'éducation puis on a le devoir
de permettre à chaque enfant au Québec
d'aller au bout de son potentiel donc on
va continuer on va continuer valoriser
la profession d'enseignants on a posé
des gestes mais il faut continuer il
faut continuer aussi
d'aider le 25% d'enfants qui ont des
difficultés d'apprentissage si on veut
augmenter la réussite c'est là qu'il
faut travailler il faut continuer aussi
à rénover nos écoles on a fait beaucoup
mais en reste encore beaucoup à faire là
on a annoncé aussi je pense qu'on doit
bien à nos jeunes des infrastructures
sportives partout au Québec puis on va
continuer de s'occuper d'éducation parce
que l'avenir
c'est nos enfants c'est nos enfants
et
maintenant
l'enjeu l'enjeu à court terme l'enjeu le
plus près simple pour les Québécois
c'est la situation économique
l'inflation fait monter le coup de la
vie les taux d'intérêt augmentent il y a
des Québécois actuellement qui ont de la
misère arriver donc oui on va envoyer de
l'aide dès le mois de décembre on va
tenir parole
[Applaudissements]
mais parlant d'économie là faut
continuer de créer de la richesse au
Québec c'est pas une fin en soi de créer
de la richesse mais ça nous donne des
moyens des moyens pour les grandes
ambitions qu'on a pour le Québec puis on
a une opportunité exceptionnelle devant
nous autres de transformer notre
économie pour faire du Québec un des
leaders au monde en économie verte on
est capable de faire et
donc c'est vraiment possible
c'est pas juste un discours on peut
s'enrichir puis réduire nos GS puis on a
un devoir
de les réduire puis éventuellement que
les éliminer nos grs parce qu'il faut
contribuer à l'effort qui doit être fait
partout sur la planète pour lutter
contre les changements climatiques on
doit ça justement à nos enfants puis oui
vous savez
pour réussir
cette immense projet économique et
écologique on va avoir besoin de tous
les bras de tous les cerveaux puis oui
j'entends le message des jeunes puis je
veux travailler avec toutes les
générations pour le réussir ce projet-là
parce que ça va marquer l'histoire du
Québec et chouette
[Applaudissements]
chouette aussi que cette immense projet
ça contribue à rapprocher la nation
québécoise des nations autochtones donc
continuons sur la voie de la vérité la
réconciliation on a besoin les uns des
autres donc il faut travailler
[Applaudissements]
vraiment
l'autre grande priorité qu'on a c'est la
santé c'est le réseau de la santé le
surtout après les deux années de
pandémie que personne n'avait prévu
qu'on a essayé de gérer de mieux
possible ben il y a des employés du
réseau de la santé qui ont été au front
depuis deux ans et demi puis là on a le
devoir plus que jamais les appuyer il
faut que notre réseau de la santé
devienne plus humain
s plus efficaces c'est le plus grand
défi de gestion qu'on a au Québec puis
on a la chance
d'avoir le bon capitaine oui oui
[Applaudissements]
un capitaine là
qui accepte
je dirais quasiment causes
réagisse mal mais de presque consacrer
les prochaines années de sa vie donc
merci Christian Dubé merci Christian
[Applaudissements]
vous savez le message qu'on a eu le
message qu'on a eu aujourd'hui ce soir
c'est continuons mais
une élection ça divise
pourtant je pense que bien plus de
choses au Québec qui nous rassemble
quelque chose qui nous divise les
Québécois forment un grand peuple quand
je clique Québécois forment un grand
peuple
je parle de tous les Québécois
de toutes les régions de tous les âmes
de toutes les origines je vais être le
premier ministre de tous les Québécois
[Applaudissements]
sont
quand je dis que les Québécois les
Québécoises font que les grandes nations
je veux évoquer tous les Québécois et
tout les Québécois de toutes les régions
et de tous les âges
de toutes les origines je vais être le
premier ministre de tout un chacun
il y a une chose que je veux mettre au
clair ce soir
au Québec tous les partis
tous les chefs sont en faveur de
l'immigration contrairement à ce qu'on
voit ailleurs ici il y a pas de partie
qui rejette les nouveaux arrivants ici
là tous les partis considèrent que
l'immigration c'est une richesse puis
l'intégration à notre belle nation c'est
un cadeau mutuel qu'on se fait
et
faut pas oublier que le plus grand
devoir d'un premier ministre du Québec
c'est de s'assurer que la langue
française garde toute sa place toute sa
vigueur le plus grand devoir d'un
Premier ministre cette protéger notre
langue on doit pas seulement arrêter
déclin du français
faut être capable de promouvoir la place
du français au Québec c'est notre devoir
comme nation québécoise et
qu'on le veuille ou non
l'avenir du français ça passe beaucoup
par notre capacité d'intégrer en
français ceux et celles qui ont choisi
récemment de bâtir leur avenir au Québec
puis dans les prochains mois on va se
parler de façon respectueuse comme on
est capable de le faire au Québec
certains qu'on va arriver avec une
vision pour rassembler tout les
Québécois derrière notre langue comme
une c'est le devoir qu'on doit se
[Applaudissements]
en terminant
terminale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je veux féliciter tous les gagnants ce
soir de tous les partis je veux aussi
remercier toutes celles et tous ceux qui
sont présentés même si on peut gagner
vous avez servi la démocratie j'ai parlé
un peu plus tôt ce soir avec Dominique
avec Gabriel avec Paul avec
Eric je les ai félicités pour leur
campagne ont été coriace
et le camp et je leur ai dit qu'on va se
parler
individuellement dans les prochaines
semaines je veux qu'on discute de
comment on peut travailler ensemble pour
les Québécois c'est sûr qu'on va avoir
encore des différents des désaccords
c'est normal
mais je veux qu'on travaille sur ce qui
nous unit et
en terminant je veux aussi remercier
tous les bénévoles tous les candidats
candidats tous les travailleurs de tous
les partis mais évidemment avec un merci
spécial à ceux de la CAQ cette victoire
c'est beaucoup votre victoire
[Applaudissements]
merci merci
merci
puis vous allez me permettre de
remercier en particulier une bénévole
qui est avec moi depuis 32 ans
vous le savez la politique là c'est pas
drôle à tous les jours il y a des
moments plus durs
cette personne là merci
[Applaudissements]
finalement je veux dire merci à ceux qui
nous ont donné leur confiance en
particulier vous allez me permettre un
merci spécial aux gens de l'Assomption
qui m'ont réélu merci aux gens de
l'Ascension
là je termine pour le réel en vous
disant j'aime le Québec j'aime les
Québécois puis vous me faites un grand
honneur de me choisir pour une deuxième
fois comme votre premier ministre une
grande responsabilité mais je vais
l'assumer avec tout mon coeur merci
bonne soirée
[Musique]